inside a synagogue in texas it was this
british man who caused terror and panic
the motives and movements of
thessalonica are now at the center of an
international investigation
from the fbi in america to counter
terror police in the uk
but it's on the streets of his hometown
blackburn where people are in complete
shock
his family today once again apologized
to the victims and said they were
surprised that he was capable of
planning the attack
in an interview with sky news vessel's
brother said how he tried to tell him to
give up
i got a call on saturday at 8 pm from
his son
my dad wants to talk to you one last
time he said
he's in a shootout with coppers he's in
america
i felt like i was in a movie i tried to
convince him i said think about your
kids your mum and dad but his mind was
made up i knew he wasn't going to get
out of there alive his intention was to
die
gulbar also told us if my brother never
had these mental health issues he
wouldn't have done this at all
tonight the family are demanding answers
they're questioning how did fessel akram
a man with a criminal record enter the
u.s get hold of a gun and keep people
hostage in a place of worship
they believe he didn't act alone
and in america the rabbi caught up in
saturday's hostage situation said he let
akram inside gave him a cup of tea and
had a chat it was during prayer um i
heard a click
and it could have been anything
and it turned out that it was his gun
it led to him being held at gunpoint for
over 10 hours
we were terrified
when i saw an opportunity
where he wasn't in a good position
the
two gentlemen who were still with me
i told them to go
i threw a chair at the gunman
and i headed for the door
in the uk counter-terror police said
they've arrested and are questioning two
teenagers from south manchester in
relation to the incident
his family told sky news that he was
motivated by the release of afia siddiki
linked to al-qaeda she is serving an
86-year sentence in a prison near the
synagogue
he's unacceptable and aborted what he
tried to do but we take some comfort
from the fact that nobody was he never
killed any of the hostages but still we
have to ask some serious questions going
there taking hostages terrorizing people
in a place of worship a synagogue
the whole it's just
mind-boggling that it took place
this now fast-paced investigation is
examining many lines of inquiry the
president of the united states is being
kept informed about what happened but
thousands of miles away in this
lancashire town it's left a community
unsettled
in saman rashid sky news blackburn